september is suicide prevention
awareness month for many people in
communities of color the process of
navigating treatment can be quite
difficult mary jane bellies joins us in
studio now to explain mary jane
local organizations want to bridge that
gap and break barriers to minority
mental health care but they say it's
going to take the community's help
racial and ethnic minority communities
still face unique struggles when it
comes to mental health dr sid carrana
from nevada mental health knows the
struggles minorities face all too well
asian asian culture the culture i come
from
we are one third less likely to seek
mental health care than the caucasian
counterparts and that comes from our own
perceptions of mental illness lack of
adequate insight in many cultures the
negative stigma about mental health
comes from fear or shame preventing
people from seeking help they do not
believe that
they will get the right care from their
treatment providers that their culture
would be understood their language would
be understood they they have a distrust
of the system and that some many times
are factors keeping them from seeking
care other factors also include the type
of community you live in lack of
transportation and lack of health
insurance dr sheldon jacobs the vice
president of nami the national alliance
of mental illness in southern nevada is
trying to change that we've
been working a little bit more with
youth as well as communities of color
and so really one of the emphasis has
been on just meeting people where they
are dr jacobs says nami is working on
partnering with other local mental
health organizations to identify those
needs so really trying to
educate
you know individuals and various
communities about mental health and then
also just trying to normalize as much as
possible by
by spreading awareness
nami has a number of services like
peer-led support groups and mental
health events free of charge
thank you mary jane
the next event called sharing hope a
night of exploring mental wellness
within the black community will take
place at city hall september 23 at 5 30.